Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
de Magalie qui me demande :
« Est-ce que le mythe de Pocahontas soutient
et encourage les violences faites aux femmes? »
Magalie, c'est une très bonne question.
J'en ai souvent parlé, j'ai souligné le fait
qu'il y avait un problème avec
Pocahontas. C'est qu'il y avait le mythe
de Pocahontas,
il y avait l'histoire de Pocahontas.
Le mythe est souvent lié à ce qu'on a vu
dans le film de Walt Disney :
Pocahontas très sexy avec la robe
qui a juste une épaule, qui sont d'une falaise,
qui est très très courbée.
Elle est une des rares princesses de Walt Disney
qui a une mini jupe très très courte
et fendue sur le côté.
Et il y a l'histoire de Pocahontas. C'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille qu'on estime avoir entre 10 et 13 ans,
à l'époque, qui a sauvé John Smith,
celui dont elle est tombée amoureuse dans le film,
mais elle l'a sauvé
contre une mort certaine
qui venait de sa communauté.
Sauf que son histoire est plus grande que ça.
Ensuite, elle s'est fait kidnapper, elle a été capturée
par les colons de Jamestown.
Elle a été mariée à un homme
qui s'appelle John Rolfe, qui était un
des premiers importateurs de tabac
en Virginie et elle n'a même pas eu
la chance de pouvoir finir sa vie sur
son propre continent, car elle est morte
en Angleterre et elle est enterrée là-bas.
Elle est morte d'une maladie pulmonaire.
L'histoire de Pocahontas
est quand même très tragique,
parce que c'est une histoire d'une jeune fille
qui n'avait même pas encore fini son adolescence,
qui a été victime de violences physiques,
de violences sexuelles, qui a été déracinée.
Et le mythe, c'est l'histoire
d'une jeune fille très sexy qui court
dans la forêt, qui parle aux colibris et ça
a amené l'idée de la femme autochtone
très libérée sexuellement,
très facile, aussi.
Malheureusement ce mythe a continué aussi
avec les histoires qui étaient rapportées,
au Québec par exemple, par les
missionnaires comme quoi les femmes
autochtones étaient très libres
sexuellement, avaient le droit
de choisir leur partenaire
et ça a contribué à dire
que les femmes autochtones étaient très faciles.
Aujourd'hui on voit aussi que ce mythe
continue et perdure puisque la quantité
de femmes assassinées ou disparues au Canada,
proportionnellement à celles qui sont
autochtones ou non-autochtones,
on sait que les femmes autochtones,
que ce soit au Canada ou aux États-Unis,
sont les premières à en être victimes.
Et c'est souvent lié à cette mythologie
qui a nourri l'histoire au Québec,
au Canada et même aux États-Unis.
Alors oui, je pense que le mythe de
Pocahontas nourrit ces violences-là.
Je pense que l'histoire véritable de
Pocahontas permettrait justement
de prévenir qu'on continue à avoir ces
idéologies faussées.
Donc, merci beaucoup Magalie pour ta question. J'espère que vous allez nous en envoyer d'autres.
J'espère aussi que vous allez
partager cette vidéo
et je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine.